welcome to this video playing war habit
or habit mohabbat could be different
things okay so we gotta ruin I have
wired I wanted to vary a bit and play a
little bit more reform yeah 63 the anti
Marshall line that nowadays some rather
popular castles what do that player a
three rookie one okay one shouldn't be
too bad so maybe a three I think they
they play a three I cried a lot in those
those kind of structures so that night a
five can be answered by Bishop e2 and
not bishops eaten I am okay so Bishop g4
maybe c3 after all or well this might
also be okay I mean 94 I can go to h1
place III later Bishop g4 is normally
not such a great idea in those positions
where d 4 is not played because the
bishop quite often is just there to be
traded so something like night to g3 and
then aged three is is getting
problematic yeah so I go I do this maybe
I should have played c 3 i'm not sure
about it this trade might have been an
achievement for black what
okay yeah it might not be so bad because
he has got c5 in very often you play
Knight a5 c5 and drop it back now you
went 94 c 5 and dropped it back so it
looks a bit strange but it's not
probably not not terribly bad my idea is
to ya know he goes back interesting so
if i take her take it his central
structure is strengthened a bit I one
day okay let's do that if he takes I'm
going to take but the rook can drop back
at least them I have some ideas with d4
on maybe Knight to f5 if he takes on a
two I have more experience from the
black site in those structures but it's
definitely an interesting position to
play that also why it shouldn't be yeah
I mean much worried about
should g5 maybe here maybe I can do
something on on those light squares
trading this Bishop Knight f-5e 3d 5
these kind of ideas
yeah well this is a thought I should
probably answer with the retreat and
then deform 96th oh yeah we can maybe in
play Knight b6 so that k didn't Knight
b6 to to get night see foreign so what I
do is I'm correcting this rook placement
it really wasn't positioned well on a to
ya Knight to c4 it's a possible reply
maybe he can go d5 hmm now that I think
of it that was a bit quick here this
route see one
hmm
it's probably not a big deal but I
really should have thought about it for
a moment that you can go d5 hiding for
some space here 1c for I can take v6 and
d5 yeah and here i thought i will take
and play possibly to it yeah and
possibly see form but I can take I mean
I can play this and take on c5 which is
not clear to me at all my day for maybe
I where do I put this Bishop probably
here to to cover to cover d three LC
three yeah I wonder can I he has
somewhat loose pieces I lose if i take
here queen bee three check king moves
look see one somehow it looks it looks
wrong I don't say don't see it I don't
see it check trying to use some I'm temp
at the moment I have some temporary
activity with e5 and so on and i hope i
can use it with with the nights um night
you for maybe takes rook checks and I
attack deform at least and but 94 okay I
thought that this would help me a little
bit the problem is that taking only 595
do tonight f7 is really bad so
yeah take it and I can take f6 here for
a pawn I can take you form the 95 Quincy
1s in fact back rank made e6 is also
interesting but he's got Quincy three
Quincy three is really a problem I can
answer it with night deform ok I have to
play a move so it doesn't help Quincy
three Quincy three I have Queen f7 this
is what i was thinking for activity you
still cannot take do tonight g 5 195
I thought h4 is just useful I didn't see
a good move frame so it seems it seems
difficult what what should he do I'm
just taking Devore next or possibly f6
so maybe I could have played something
about my background I mean I cannot I
cannot live with with the Queen c1
almost made all the time it's not moving
sister connected black resigns no I mean
he is connected but you resigned yeah I
don't know computer gives it is equal
the computer as usual is completely
unfazed and takes him yeah the first
thing that that I notice is that this
idea wasn't working at all because of
check check this little tactic so now g5
would be more interesting but he can
just do this yeah I computer is totally
cool yeah it simply takes takes on e5
but probably that's that's almost the
only move that can be played here you
should have least tried that probably he
didn't see rookie 5 because if you don't
have this resource which in fact even
wins then then I'm winning an IDF 7 is
just too strong so bit of a lucky win
yay he simply didn't see it and and
resigned um so it that means that some
of our here I'm having an advantage yes
yeah about one pawn according to the
computer rooks e 2 e 1 is better no
that's here and now g3 sg3 is better
than h4 because of this Queen f4 yeah I
am okay I get it g3 is better I mean I
just wanted to play a move that that
gives me some looked for the king and i
thought h4 would be helpful maybe to
support no not this one
to support and later Knight to g5 this
is why I went h4 but g3 is better
because it keeps this a foursquare
covered until what really is better he
cannot take this no wins very very
convincingly yeah interesting game
thanks for watching